>> Greg: OH, I'M SORRY.
YOU KNOW DIDN'T EVEN KNOW I WAS
ON.
ALL RIGHT, WITH A LEFT LISTEN TO
BILL MARR AND ADMIT THAT THEY'VE
GONE TOO FAR?
OR ABOUT SIX MONTHS OUT FROM THE
MIDTERMS AND MANY PEOPLE ARE
TOAST AND THEY KNOW IT ONE
STRATEGIST TELLS AT THE WEST
SIDE OUT THE GENERIC MOUND OF
EARTH THAT WOULD MAKE NO SENSE.
I THINK THIS COULD BE A BIBLICAL
DISASTER.
IT IS THE REALITY WE ARE IN AS
DEMOCRATS AND NO ONE WANTS TO
FACE IT."
THE STRATEGIST WAS THEN FIRED
FOR MENTIONING THE BIBLE.
A LOT OF BIBLE TODAY.
SO I GOT THEM HERE?
THERE IS INFLATION, IMMIGRATION,
COVERT MANDATES AND CRIME.
NOT TO MENTION THE OLD GHOUL
FLOATING AROUND THE WHITE HOUSE
LIKE A PLASTIC BAG IN A
PARKING LOT.
THAT IS THE BEST DESCRIPTION.
SHE CAN'T BLAME VOTERS IT'S ALL
IN THEM AND THEIR POLICIES FOR
EXAMPLE.
SMILEY MARTIN THEOLOGIAN
SACRAMENTO SHOOTER HE WAS GIVEN
A $75 SETTLEMENT FROM THE CITY
JUST WEEKS BEFORE THE SHOOTING.
THAT'S MORE MONEY THAN I MAKE IN
A DAY.
YES.
SO NO WONDER THE ESSO SMILING.
APPARENTLY HE FILED A LAWSUIT
INVOLVING JOE GILLARD BECAUSE
THEY WERE BACKED UP.
THEY PAID HIM OFF.
CALIFORNIA PRISONS WAY MORE
MONEY THAN I DO AFTER DRINKING
GOLD AND INFUSED VODKA.
SO NOW GIVING PAID OUT TO MASS
SHOOTING SUSPECTS.
THE ONE OR EVEN LEFT TIME
LEFTIES LIKE HOLDING OUT JEN
COMEY TELLING JOE ROGAN ALL
THINGS OF CHANGE.
>> IF YOU LIKE ON SAME GUY BUT
FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN SPENT
$6 TRILLION TO STAY HOME.
I UNDERSTAND WE HAD TO DO
SOMETHING WITH THE PANDEMIC I
MEMBER WHEN IT TRILLION DOLLARS
WAS TOO MUCH A SPOT IN ANYTHING.
WE AND SPENT A TRILLION TO
BAILOUT THE ECONOMY IN 2008.
FIVE YEARS AGO GNOMES TALK ABOUT
ABOLISHING THE POLICE YOU KNOW.
THERE IS NO TALK ABOUT PREGNANT
MEN.
[LAUGHS]
LOOTING WAS STILL ILLEGAL HOW I
CHANGED?
NO.
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE 20 YEARS
AGO ARCHER LEARNING IS A BAD
THING WOULD'VE POSTED THEN.
SO I'VE BEEN CHANGED.
>> Greg: MAYBE YOU HAVEN'T
WE'RE SURE IT SOUNDED LIKE MORE
AND MORE LIKE SOMEONE I KNOW.
♪ ♪
[LAUGHS]
>> Greg: YEAH, GODLIKE.
YOU.
YOU KNOW IT'S HAPPENING OUT A
BILL BARR?
IS THAT HILARIOUS?
>> Kat: UP KIND OF HAD THAT
HAPPEN BECAUSE I'M LIBERTARIAN
HAVE BEEN.
YOU BECOME MORE CONSERVATIVE.
BUT IT'S NOT THAT.
I SHOULD BE THE LAUGH MOST
DEMOCRATS ON CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM BECAUSE MY VIEWS ON THE
DRUG WAR.
BUT NOW THAT I THINK THAT YOU
SHOULD GO TO JAIL FOR ASSAULT
WITH A DEADLY WEAPON THAT MAKES
ME APPARENTLY CONSERVATIVE.
>> YOU'RE NOW INTO THE JOHN
BIRCH SOCIETY.
I JUST DECLINE THE INVITATION TO
BECOME COMPLETELY INSANE.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S IN TO
ANY BETTER IF YOU LIKE WHEN
YOU'RE IN SUCH A CRAZY SITUATION
YOU'RE SINGLE THESE CRAZY
THINGS.
YOU GET USED TO IT.
THEY PROBABLY DON'T REALIZE JUST
HOW CRAZY THEY SOUND IN THESE
BUBBLES WERE EVERYTHING SAY
THAT, STUFF.
>> Greg: IF YOU'RE IN A BUBBLE
FOR A LONG TIME YOU CAN JUST
BECOME THE BUBBLE.
YOU KNOW TYRESE THEY SEEM TO BE
MORE WORRIED ABOUT POWER THAN
THE ACTUAL CONSEQUENCES THAT
LEAD TO THAT.
DO NOT WORRY THAT THE GOING ALL
MY GOD WITH THE SOLVE CRIME.
OF THE SOLVE THIS AND THAT.
INSTEAD IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU LOSE
POWER.
>> Tyrus: SETTING THAT I THINK
THIS IS ACTUALLY A GOOD THING
BUT WERE SEEING.
I KNOW IT SOUNDS CRAZY WHEN YOU
STEP OUTSIDE YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD
AND SEE WAS GOING ON.
WERE SEEING THE END OF
TRIBALISM.
THANK YOU TO THE DEMOCRATS THE
PROGRESSIVE PUSH SO HARD THEY
JUST LET THE TRUTH WOULD GO WITH
THEM.
AT SOME POINT BEING A HUMAN
BEING AND BEING SAFE IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN WEARING THE BLUE
DONKEY ON YOUR SHIRT IS GONE SO
FAR THAT THEIR LEFT CENTER IS
CONSIDERED CONSERVATIVE.
THIS WAS A AND ASK TO BE
CONSERVATIVE?
MEANS YOU WANT SMALL GOVERNMENT,
YOU DON'T WANT THEM ON YOUR
BACK, YOU DON'T WANT TO HIM IN
YOUR POCKET, YOU WANT TO TAKE
CARE YOUR FAMILY AND APPROVE
YOUR LIFE.
THAT IN AND OF ITSELF IF YOU
HAVE EVERY AMERICAN WHO WORKED
TO TRY TO PUSH THEIR SIDE OF THE
FENCE WOULD AGREE WITH YOU.
THAT IS MORE IMPORTANT TO THEM
NOW BEEN BELONGING TO THE TRUTH
BECAUSE THE TRUTH IS THAT
[BLEEP] CRAZY.
THAT'S WHY BILL MOORE SUDDENLY
GOING, AND HATES REPUBLICANS.
YOU THINK THAT WE DON'T LIKE THE
ENVIRONMENT IS ALL HIS LITTLE
ISSUES MONA COMES ON A BASIC
HUMAN BEING RIGHTS BEING A HUMAN
BEING AND TAKE CARE OF YOURSELF
BECOME AGREES OF US THERE.
>> Greg: WHITAKER THIS GUY AND
SACRAMENTO HOW CAN HUMAN BEINGS
AGREED SOME LIKE THAT I JUST PAY
OFF A GUY AND HE GOES AND KILLS
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE?
>> Matt: A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
KILLED IN THAT MASS SHOOTING
EVENT, ALL FOUR OF THEM WERE
BLOODS OR CRIBS.
ONE OF THEM HAD A DEVICE TO MAKE
HIS PISTOL AUTOMATIC.
IT ESSENTIALLY WAS A SHOOT-OUT
AT THE O.K. CORRAL.
THIS IS SOMEONE WALKING IN
WALMART NOT TO MAKE LIGHT OF
MASS SHOOTING BUT IT'S PRETTY
SERIOUS BUT THIS IS GANG
VIOLENCE IN THE MIDDLE OF
SACRAMENTO.
THIS GUY GOT OUT FOUR YEARS OF A
10-YEAR PRISON SENTENCE.
FOR THE MYSTIC VIOLENCE FROM ALL
FOUR OF THEM THAT WERE ARRESTED
ALL HAD FAMILIES
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
BUT BRINGING PUNCH LINE HERE.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE MOST
RESTRICTIVE GUN LAWS ON THE
BOOKS IN ALL FOUR OF THESE GUYS
WERE FELONS AND SHOULD HAVE THE
GUNS.
TO ME IT IS NOT A MATTER OF
ENFORCING THE LAW IS THAT WERE
ALLOWING VIOLENT CRIMINALS TO
UNDERSERVED THEIR SENTENCES AND
THEN PUT THEM ON THE STREETS,
AND THAT IT TURNS OUT DIFFERENT
AND THAT ALL BY THE WAY WE DID
GIVE HIM $7,000 SETTLEMENT FOR
SOME OF THAT HAPPENED IN JAIL
THE LAST TIME HE WAS THERE.
IT MAKES NO SENSE AND THE SWELL
OF AMERICANS SHAKE THEIR HEADS
IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE TYPE
OF POLICY THE DEMOCRATS WON'T
SPREAD ALL THE WAY ACROSS.
>> Greg: THAT'S A SCARY PART
THAT IS NOT SHRINKING ITS
GROWING SHANNON DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE GONNA BE ON BILL MOORE TO
DISCUSS?
>> Shannon: THE FIRST TIME
EVER ONE ON TV WAS ON HIS SHOW
POLITICALLY INCORRECT.
>> Greg: 25 YEARS AGO?
SO HE CAN ACTUALLY SAY THAT IS
NOT PARTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
BECAUSE HE HAD ALL THAT TIME SAY
HEY GUYS MAY BID ON A MEMBER.
>> Shannon: I THINK TYRUS MADE
SUCH A GOOD POINT, MOM'S FRIENDS
WERE FURIOUS OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
HE ALSO FELT SCARED AND DON'T
FEEL SAFE.
THEY WORRY ABOUT TRAVELING
HAVING THEIR KIDS ON THE ROAD.
WE LOOK AT THINGS LIKE REAL
CLEAR POLITICS AVERAGE HOW DO
YOU THINK THE COUNTRIES OF THE
MOVE TO THE RIGHT DIRECTION
QUESTION MARKETS UPSIDE DOWN BY
37%.
THE DEMOCRATS OF THE
WHITE HOUSE, THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE SAYS NOT A GOOD NUMBER
FOR THEM GOING INTO THE FALL.
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THE COUNTRY NO
SPACE TO GO TO A HAND BASKET.
>> Greg: WHAT DID YOU SAY?
>> Shannon: IS IN THE BIBLE.
>> Tyrus: WE HAVE DONE FOR
THAT PICTURE BACKUP?
HE LITERALLY HAS A BLUEPRINT ON
HIS FACE THAT IS A MURDERER.
>> HE KILLED AT LEAST THREE
TIMES AND GOT A REPORT 40s THE
DIAMOND TEAR WHICH MEANS THAT
HE'S A MASTER AT HIS CRAFT.
THE DEN TIP YOU OFF THAT THAT'S
NOT THE GUY WE THINK WE DID, HE
LOADED UP.